pour marquer un point d'arrêt à cette
mode du suicide au shopping
la mode du suicide voilà comment didier
lombard alors pdg de france télécom
décrivez la vague de suicides que
connaissait son entreprise que se
passe-t-il chez france télécom début
2000 l'entreprise publique ouvre son
capital
au même moment la concurrence fait rage
dans le milieu des télécoms le malaise
s'installe et des premiers cas de
suicides sont recensés rapidement les
syndicats font le lien avec les méthodes
de management exemple dès 2003 à
entendre ces militants l'histoire de
gens ne serait pas unique et de
s'interroger sur les causes qui ont
poussé trois autres personnes issues de
la même agence à se donner la mort en
l'espace de moins de 12 mois cruel
hasard ou effets pervers d'un management
les années passent et l'entreprise
continue sa mutation didier lombard
devient pdg de france télécom en 2005
avec une mission assurer le virage de la
privatisation pour ça le groupe voulait
supprimer 22 mille postes entre 2006 et
2008 et procédé à dix mille changement
de métier le pdg était assez clair sur
la méthode
je ferai les départs d'une façon ou
d'une autre par la fenêtre ou par la
porte
les cadres témoigner alors de ses
méthodes à visage caché
ceux des métaux de la suppression de
mobilité forcée ne rejoint pas le stress
des fixation d'objectifs inatteignables
enfin tout un tas de méthodes qui ne
vise c'est chaud c'est que les gens parc
ne s'y sont pas d'accord pour le faire
malgré ces alertes en 2009 la vague de
suicides continue à lundi difficile pour
ces employés de france télécom ils se
retrouvent sur leur lieu de travail au
pied de cet immeuble d'où s'est jetée
vendredi leur collègue âgé de 32 ans
mais la direction de l'entreprise et le
gouvernement ni le lien entre suicides
et conditions de travail à france
télécom
je crois que le suicide est une affaire
trop grave trop personnelle pour qu'on
puisse réduire ce phénomène que l'on
constate chez france télécom un problème
d'organisation d'entreprise
en septembre 2009 suite au 24e suicide
didier lombard se rend pour la première
fois sur place accueilli par des huées
et des appels à la démission
notre direction reste dans le déni le
plus total et vous savez pourquoi il
fait ça je vais vous dire pourquoi il
fait ça ils font ça parce que nous
sommes des fonctionnaires à 80% dans une
entreprise du cac 40
et quand on a un fonctionnaire en a
qu'une chose à faire c'est fermer sa
gueule
le gouvernement commet d'un audit c'est
l'inspection du travail fourni un
rapport accablant mettant en cause le
management et début 2010 didier lombard
quitte son poste et la justice
intervient une enquête sur les suicides
a été ouverte aujourd'hui par le parquet
de paris pour harcèlement moral
à l'origine de la plainte le syndicat
sud qui met en cause la direction de
l'entreprise 39 cas sont retenus dans le
cadre de la procédure judiciaire dont
dix neuf suicides 12 tentatives et 8
dépression les syndicats eux avaient
comptabilisé au moins 35 suicides
[Musique]